happy birthday Ashley I hope this year
is one of the best ones yet guys the
Olsen twins have surfaced on Instagram
to wish Ashley Benson a happy 30th
birthday and honestly this is probably
the best birthday present anyone could
ever get
happy birthday Ashley I hope this year
is one of the best ones yet we're
sending you long magical and can't wait
to meet you soon bye Ashley shared the
13 second clip to her Instagram writing
quote dreams do come true yeah it's
great now if you listen to the end of
the message you'll hear the Olsen twins
say they can't wait to meet Ashley can't
wait to meet you soon bye so maybe
you're wondering why M K and a would
send Ashley be a birthday message
they've never met well here's why Ashley
Benson has made her love for Ashley and
mary-kate Olsen very well known over the
years in fact while doing press to
promote her sunglass collection last
year she could not stop talking about
her obsession with the Olsen twins
she told W Magazine quote to be honest
with you I base my looks off the Olsen
twins I've been their biggest fan since
I was born
[Music]
that never gets old she took her love
for the famous twins even further while
talking to WWD though she said quote I
think I'm an Olsen twin and I try to
find out where they are at all times in
New York this is so weird and stalkerish
I know a few places where they hang out
so I go there to see if they're there
I've never had luck yet
well it looks like her luck is changing
because getting the elusive Olsen twins
who are notoriously private to make a
video message is kind of a big deal
Queen but that's not the only sweet
birthday shout out that Ashley got her
longtime girlfriend Cara Delevingne also
had the sweetest post to share yeah she
posted all these sweet shots to
Instagram including this one the pair
kissing in the bath so cute and she
wrote the most adorable message she
calls Ashley her quote safe place and
also says you let me be silly you let me
be wild
you keep me free secure and curious I
feel like I've known you my entire life
and I am so proud of watching you grow
into the woman that you always dreamt of
being she's one of the people that
helped me love myself when I needed it
most and I really needed it she showed
me what real love is and show me how to
accept it which was a lot harder than
they thought I love you sprinkles Cara
also lists out all the cute nicknames
that she has for Ashley sprinkles
chunji angel face grumpy sweet cheeks
and this last one but much of course
Cara and Ashley are usually pretty
private so this does feel super special
Ashley and Cara met on the set of the
2018 movie her smell
and have been inseparable ever since
fun fact they also starred in a music
video together for the movie together
alright guys that's it for today
we here at ET are wishing Ashley Benson
a very happy birthday though let's be
honest nothing that we say or do will
top that awesome twin message happy
birthday for all the latest on Ashley
Cara and the Olsen twins stick with all
things et until next time I have Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]